[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a thriller drama film called
monolith
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with an advertisement
from a futuristic car brand named
monolith the presenter from the
advertisement states that the car is
awarded as the safest car in the world
and has a number of unique safety
features he claims that the car is
extremely modern and has several
features like unbreakable glass strong
tires rigid body and many more to keep
its riders safe from every possible
theft and damage an ai-connected
smartphone app is used to control all
the features while being inside the car
a virtual assistant called lilith helps
to interact with the user interface of
the car in the next scene we see a
mother carrying her kid inside the same
ai car to his granny's home while
talking to the ai assistant lilith we
get to know that the mother's name is
sandra and her two-year-old son is david
her husband carl is a pilot who could
not join them due to his busy schedule
the car is so advanced that it can even
detect the weight of the passengers
inside the vehicle later carl calls them
and informs them that he is at the
central airport after his duty and
misses them a lot just then someone
knocks on the door and carl says his
goodbye and leaves meanwhile david
starts becoming fussy so sandra hands
him her smartphone to keep him occupied
quiet down david and check your dms
after some time sandra takes a halt at
the gas station on the side of the road
she then takes david inside the washroom
and changes his diapers while some girls
are seen giggling the gas station also
has a supermarket where sandra buys her
son his favorite snacks while paying at
the counter sandra notices someone
trying to break into her car outside
instead of being worried she just takes
out her smartphone and locks the vehicle
using the smart app as sandra is busy
inspecting the situation she doesn't
even notice that david has been
separated from her after she realizes
that david is lost she screams and
searches for him around the supermarket
she rushes outside and even calls a
stranger assuming that david is with him
she seems to be totally freaked out
until she finds david with the same
three ladies whom she met earlier at the
washroom sandra immediately puts david
into her car and activates the vault
mode feature this disengages her from
what's happening outside and she finally
breathes a sigh of relief after leaving
the gas station sandra still has a long
distance to drive until they reach her
mother-in-law's house due to the long
ride sandra feels bored and decides to
call her childhood friend jessa to check
on her jessa receives the call and
informs her that she is near the central
airport at a hotel she even tells that
she has been staying at the hotel with
carl sandra is devastated at the
revelation of her friend having an
affair with her husband she becomes so
frustrated that she does not even bother
to enter her mother-in-law's house after
reaching the entrance she continues
calling carl but he doesn't pick up and
pretends to be busy fed up with the lies
sandra decides to take matters into her
own hands and hence sets her journey to
find carl at the central airport in los
angeles on her way a board shows that
the distance to los angeles is about 320
miles after a while lilith the smart ai
mentions that a serious accident has
taken place on the main highway which
will slow them down she then suggests
sandra take the bypass road which will
save them a lot of time however the ai
also mentions that the route is deserted
and barely has any passengers sandra who
is adamant on confronting her husband
does not think twice and takes the
alternative route later it gets dark and
sandra starts to feel difficulty in
driving the car the fog on the way also
intensifies which affects her vision of
the road in front of her on her way she
finds no human settlements or any other
vehicles however she finds an electrical
substation located in the middle of
nowhere she glances over the place but
soon drives away the place is so
deserted that the only beings present
there are wild animals suddenly a
nervous sandra loses her focus and
crashes into a deer which was trying to
cross the road because of the collision
david starts crying and like always
sandra hands over her smartphone to calm
him down here david catch up on your
dank memes she then immediately gets out
to check on the animal but it appears to
be almost dead the deer is stuck below
the front part of the car and because of
it sandra is unable to move her car
ahead as sandra is trying to figure out
the situation she forgets that she has
left david alone in the car meanwhile as
david is playing with the cell phone he
accidentally opens the ai car app he
moves his finger around the opened app
and without sandra's notice activates
the vault feature of the car this
feature protects the passengers inside
from all kinds of disturbances and
danger sandra realizes the gravity of
the situation and tries her best to open
the door but it's already too late as
sandra is locked outside the car she
tries her best to make the two-year-old
david switch off the vault mode but he
doesn't understand a word and simply
keeps on playing with the phone later
sandra panics and starts shouting at the
little kid which startles him and he
drops the smartphone under his seat here
sandra gets to know that the monolith
car's features are not just an
advertisement but it also performs in
reality even when sander tries to break
the glass with a rock not a single
scratch can be seen on the window glass
huh should have gone with the tesla
seeing all her efforts go in vain sandra
decides to seek other options she begins
walking back to the electrical
substation which she noticed before
after some walking she reaches the
station jumps over the fence and cries
for help however she gets no response
and the station seems to be empty with
no workers present at the moment after
this sandra enters one of the rooms and
finds some necessary items inside she
takes a flashlight to use at night and a
big wrench to help her break the glass
of the locked car just as she leaves the
substation she notices a wild animal
following her as sandra rushes back a
coyote attacks her so she climbs onto
the roof of the car despite her best
efforts to scare off the animal it
remains unfazed in a last ditch attempt
sandra starts banging the car with the
wrench and an alarm starts blaring which
finally makes the coyote retreat just
then sandra notices david having
difficulties breathing despite the
situation she manages to calm david and
he finally starts breathing and soon
falls asleep after a bit of thinking
sandra too becomes tired and falls
asleep on the bonnet of the car the next
day sandra wakes up when the sun is
already bright she then immediately
rushes to check david's condition inside
the car she finds her baby weak and
feeble because of his hungry stomach and
dehydration one of the features of the
car also displays the temperature of the
surroundings which appear to be
increasing slowly the condition is a
curse to sandra as the place is
completely isolated with no humans
around sandra then decides to seek help
and follows the road despite being
severely dehydrated she proceeds to walk
the long journey she also knows the
risks of leaving david alone in the
overheated car but she has no choice but
to seek help fortunately she comes
across a river where she drinks and
cleans herself after gaining some
respite she continues her journey and
encounters steep hills along the path
after walking several miles sandra
finally comes across an old airfield
where she discovers a jet meanwhile the
temperature inside the monolith car
rises up causing it to instantly start
the emergency cooling fan after reaching
the abandoned jet sandra enters and
discovers some alcoholic drinks a gallon
of gasoline a lighter and a pair of
spare airplane tires she consumes some
alcohol and immediately gathers the
necessary items after that sandra uses
the gasoline to burn the two tires in
hopes of attracting help she then takes
the gallon and fills it with the river
water slowly sandra walks back to the
place where she left david in the next
scene sandra hurries to the car and
finds david all weak and turning red she
tries calling out to him but david does
not answer or move the temperature
inside the car has increased
significantly and the emergency cooling
fans have become ineffective seeing the
state of her son sandra immediately
climbs the roof and pours the water she
brought from the river but all her
efforts go into vain thinking that her
child will have to die inside the
high-tech vehicle she again starts to
hit the car window with the wrench but
it just wastes her energy later sandra
tries to light a fire outside the car in
hopes that the sensors will detect the
smoke and open the windows but none of
this happens
instead the emergency cooling fans stop
running to prevent the smoke from
entering inside fatigued sandra falls to
the ground and has a vision of her and
carl visiting the scene of the accident
a year later there she realizes her
mistakes and still blames carl for
david's death
after some time she wakes up to a noise
and finds it all to be her dream to make
the situation worse the coyote from last
night again appears in front of her
sandra decides to hide from it and tries
to climb on the roof of the car but as
the car's temperature is extremely high
she can't stay there and instead slides
below the car there the coyote bites her
leg and this is when sandra realizes
that it is the deer that the coyote is
after as soon as the coyote drags the
deer out the car starts rolling
backwards the deer was the reason the
car was held in position sandra
immediately gets out from under the car
and tries to stop it from sliding back
despite her best efforts the car
continues to roll edging closer to a
fall however a small chunk of rock
obstructs the car and it finally stops
as sandra stares from the cliff she
remembers the cartoon she saw earlier at
the gas station where the diamond was
obtained after the safe was broken she
then thinks of pushing the car down to
unlock the doors sandra is well aware of
the fact that her plans might have
consequences but she is left with no
other choice and decides to go with it
she grabs the wrench and starts breaking
the rock which was obstructing the tire
after successfully removing the rock
sandra purposely pushes the car down the
cliff with the baby still inside as the
car is thrown into the air its built-in
ai starts to function and immediately
realizes that the car is falling from a
height the features of the car get to
work and shift its balance studying the
gravitational pressure to fall upright
without causing any harm to david since
the car was designed to deactivate the
vault mode at the time of an accident to
let the rescuers come in the doors
finally open as soon as the car strikes
the ground sander climbs down the cliff
and approaches it despite the
devastating fall the car appears as if
someone just placed it there finding the
locked door open sandra hurriedly takes
david out of the car and opens his
clothes to help him cool down
seeing david's weak health conditions
sandra resolves to get out of the place
as soon as possible before sandra gets
in the car to drive the whole system
gets restarted with the help of lilith
sandra sets the car into extreme
off-road mode and starts climbing the
cliff in front of her the car appears to
be made for very extreme conditions and
easily gets past the steep cliff
miraculously sandra reaches the off road
she chose and heads for the hospital in
the final scene of the movie we see
sandra and david arriving at the
hospital david is kept on the hospital
bed beside sandra and is connected with
multiple tubes sandra seems worried
about david until he opens his eyes and
calls her mommy for the first time the
movie ends as sandra is delighted by her
son calling her out little did sandra
know david was speaking to the car
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching